so basically simply based on the fact
that searching came out last weekend and
this weekend we got the nun and
peppermint this is the weekend I should
have gone on vacation like this is the
weekend I should have missed the movie
well what the [ __ ] do I know
[Music]
peppermints why do they call it that
I'm really glad right now I'm like wait
why is it called peppermint they never
call her peppermint they never reference
peppermint I don't think that I can
recall there's no reference to
peppermint so it's just a weird title to
have for this movie I guess this is the
part where the possibility that this is
based on some graphic novel comes into
play I don't know though I suppose one
quick google search could inform me as
to whether or not that is the case but
to address that based on my motivation
that's that's not gonna happen so I'm
just gonna continue to wonder why they
call it that
in any case peppermint is the story of
soccer mom turned vigilante Jennifer
Garner's in the lead role this gang does
a hit a drive by shooting it kills her
husband kills her daughter she
disappears for five years to train
somewhere to return as Sarah Connor
incarnate and get revenge on they talk
about what I liked about this movie
first of all I like Jennifer Garner and
I like Jennifer Garner's execution with
the character and I like the movies
attempt at what they were doing with her
character
I say attempt because as the great ben
mendelsohn as Daggett and the Dark
Knight Rises told us one doesn't get
what I liked about Jennifer Garner is
she looks like she knew what she was
doing I feel like she really trained for
this role I don't know again a quick
google search could do it but I really
lack the [ __ ] motivation to research
this movie I'm not doing an in-depth
film analysis dive on a grade B revenge
tale named after a [ __ ] Christmas
cane flavor but for Jennifer Garner's
part she really looked like she knew
what she was doing she was jacked up
over what they attempted to do with her
character they attempted to show that
someone in her position is not gonna be
entirely saying you get the feeling she
is at least a little crazy in this movie
not just because she's hallucinating her
dead daughter I get that but she's like
threatening other deadbeat dads like
threatening their lives Randy the dude
was a deadbeat dad what was he like put
a gun in his mouth and threatened his
life deadbeat pep-talk sure but at least
he told her son not to talk to strangers
dad cared at least in that sense he gets
drunk all the time shirt maybe he's
buying booze to forget the pain maybe
his wife died right in front of him
surely you can empathize with that just
her separation of what's acceptable
what's reality it's just kind of cracked
but someone who goes from living a
normal life to killing people without
remorse it would be a little crack I
like the fact this movie at least
address that because a lot of movies are
like nah they're just the same person
they just kill people now that's not
really how it would be
when people were dying it was
entertaining enough and there's a lot of
blood being thrown on the screen in my
grade be revenge tale I enjoy it I'm
just old-school like that with my
revenge tales and obviously this movies
not going for an Oscar it's not trying
to be some modern masterpiece you can
always tell what a movie like this is
going for from the blood spatter there's
a lot you can tell by blood spatter when
it comes to a crime scene and a movie
scene in a movie when the blood spatter
is lighter in texture maybe lighter in
color and then as it pulls onto the
floor maybe it gets a little darker
you're probably there for a legit crime
drama because there is an attempt to
make the blood look at least a little
real but upon exiting the human body if
the blood is thick coagulated gel like
it almost looks like they mix slime in
with blood just like way too much corn
syrup you're there for a slasher flick
gore no or great be revenge tale you
just stalk so right out the gate you
know what this movie's going for however
among the blood spatter there has to be
a good story or at least some could
resolve some good resolution something
can really get behind what you're like
yeah rooting for you because the setup
led us to here and now we're executing
it and you're executing them this movie
doesn't really go that route though
maybe I'm being a bit too traditional I
know the cinematic thing right now is to
go into unexpected territory make
unexpected turns and decisions but
sometimes the formula works because the
formula works if you set these ones up
to be the [ __ ] have those be the
ones she goes after after the flashback
backstory of how she got to this point
near the beginning of the movie three on
her hit list or dead one of them you
actually see get taken out in a very
quick scene you don't really know what
you're watching yeah then someone's like
what about this other person they're
like yeah he's dead too I guess he died
off-screen so that makes for four people
on her [ __ ] list get taken out and the
movies just kind of breezes over it does
I want to concentrate on her going after
the big fish like their boss one who
actually gave the order and I'm glad
they're all thinking big picture you
can't just breeze over the deaths of the
ones we actually saw kill her family I
can see the movie having a couple of
bodies show up without showing her kill
them it was like a mystery we're trying
to figure it out with the movie like
it's mask of the phantasm or something I
would make sense but we already know
she's the one who's doing it so by not
showing her kill these people you're
kind of robbing the audience because the
movie made it personal to the audience
by showing the trigger men actually kill
her family like imagine the crow where
it doesn't actually show eric draven
kill t-bird or Tintin we just hear about
it having them die off-screen just feels
really cheap it feels like they didn't
show that for
sake of showing her kill more people who
didn't really have a first-hand
influence in killing her family like
imagine in Star Wars someone has an axe
to grind with an imperial officer like
Grand Admiral Thrawn has this whole
revenge quest if they kill stormtroopers
along the way it's not the same you
don't get that gratification it says in
the beginning of the movie they
essentially wipe out half of the revenge
quest there's more downtime than I would
have liked and it kind of bogged the
movie down you want to give filler show
us how she trained to get this good in
the subsequent five years they don't
even see that that would have been more
interesting than things they show as
filler in this movie as in the end
peppermint had a couple of attempts to
be more than what it was but in reality
just kind of fell flat as a revenge Dale
peppermint like the nun I'm just not
gonna remember it in t-minus one day ya
already forgot again even a Method Man
cameo couldn't save this one Method Man
has a small role in this movie one could
call it a cameo you know I like Method
Man Zoe's like I like Jennifer Garner
anyone I recognize in this movie I like
but I guess you just can't save them all
the movie is still the movie are you so
peppermint have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you